so i mentioned to you offline that i'm
of finishing up on the
rise and fall of the third reich i'm not
sure if you have
anything in your exploration interesting
to say
but the use of religion by dictators
or the lack of the use of religion by
dictators
whether we're talking about stalin which
is mostly secular
i apologize if i'm historically
incorrect on this but i believe it's
a secular and hitler i think there's
some
controversy about how much religion
played a role in his own personal life
and
in general in terms of influencing
the using it to manipulate
the public but definitely the church
played a role
um do you have a sense of the use of
religion
by governments to control the
populations
by dictators for example or is that
outside of your
little explorations as a religious
scholar
it's not outside of my framework
absolutely not um i think that
it's done routinely um propaganda
is done routinely um especially
there's nothing more powerful than
religion to get people
to act i think um
i have my mother's jewish my father is
was roman catholic okay from irish
extraction
and so both um members
both both great-grandparents came here
under duress
because they were being um what would
you call it
uh there was an act of genocide on both
sides
being done by other cultures okay so on
the one hand
obviously we know about the holocaust
okay so they came the great grandparents
came here to
avoid that and they made it um on the
other hand
there was an english um genocide
we just have to say it of the irish um
it was called a famine but it wasn't one
it was a staged thing and so um
millions of irish left ireland on coffin
ships
is what they called them because they
usually wouldn't get here mine happened
to get here
okay so those that's the context that
i'm coming from
so in each case for one thing the irish
weren't considered
you know there was catholics weren't
considered
they were considered to be terrible and
there was a lot of anti-caste
rhetoric here in the united states uh
which is kind of strange because one of
the
in fact the most wealthy colonial family
were the carols in maryland and they
were catholic so
when you look at the united states our
history and you see the separation of
church and state
do you want to know where that came from
that came from those guys
they convinced george washington and
thomas jefferson
i mean they couldn't vote yet they had
they had
they have their names on the
constitution
is that not a strange contradiction so
here's here you can see how
you know propaganda works there was
anti-catholic propaganda
there was anti-jewish propaganda and all
and a lot of it was that you know these
people weren't
human they weren't human beings um
another thing i'd like to
say is that when the irish did come here
and they were indentured a lot of times
indentured servants
um but that's a that's terminology
then what is an indentured servant
slave pretty much
so in that sense religion can be used uh
derogatory yeah derogatory as a useful
grouping mechanism of saying this is the
other
and you know it's powerful too because
behind it is a
force of um you know what people can
tend to be sacred a sacred force
right so you know it's up to god
to you know decide who's you know so you
have to go along with what god says of
course
well that's basically um that's not the
contact event you know the contact
event is is usually some type of very
specific
legitimate event that a person has with
something that
is non-human or considered divine
but when when religions become
narrativized i would call it by
different institutions
that's when you're in danger of getting
propaganda
you